hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this big piece of land and
are prototyping a more sustainable way
of living not sure how it's going to go
but let's see and in the previous video
we opened up the well on the
neighborland
and went a bit sketchy and but some guys
went inside clean it up close the lid
so we now have a functioning weld that
actually fills itself up pretty quickly
so that's good and in today's video
we're actually going to wire it up to
make sure we have water running in our
container and our washing machine and
water tap and these kind of things work
so we're going to get the components set
up the system and actually give it a
test run
[Music]
do
[Music]
so i've been doing quite some digging
into uh yeah the pump system and how
we're going to use it so
let me explain in this video what's
going to happen so you start off
basically if you have water somewhere
that you need a pump in this case we
have a submersible pump so it goes in
the well uh did why it's this shape is
that you can also use it in a borehole
so if you drill down a deep hole
this one slides in there so you put in
the pump you wire it up with electricity
and then it just pumps water out from
here so technically that's kind of all
you need the pump or water comes out so
you could puzzle a bit with these pieces
so in this way you should actually just
have water coming out and you could
obviously extend the pipe and make sure
it runs to whatever you want it to open
the top and the water comes out the
downside of this is
that every time you open the tap the
pump goes on because it needs to pump
the water
so if you open a little bit bomb goes on
which means the pump goes on and off
very often
which is not good for the pump
so what you would have in between here
is what they call a pressure tank
i think they're actually kind of genius
wait let me get it
so before we go into the nerdy side of
setting up the system let's just give a
test to the pump
just because it's here it's fun it's hot
and because last week we cleaned the
well so it should be quite quick to get
some flowing water on the land
so we'll just make a new lid lower the
pump and hook it up to extension cords
and see what happens
coming
so we're now using the pump
and it uses around
1300 watt
we have a bit more stuff standing on
so yeah drawing a lot of energy
nice one
okay so that all seems to be good now
the plant's got some water and it's time
to go back to the water system and
pressure tank still need to explain you
why they are so cool so pressure tank is
here to make sure that every time you
want water the pump doesn't necessarily
have to start so in the old days people
used to build for instance a water tower
so you pump up the water in a big
quantity and then slowly with gravity
you have pressure on your water and you
can use it but the downside is well you
need to build this big tower so what you
have nowadays is pressure tanks and what
this basically means is a tank metal one
and there's a balloon inside
and as the
water pumps in the balloon with air
shrinks but it kind of wants to expand
so this gives a pressure to the water so
in this way you can fill up your
pressure tank with water
and the balloon here gets compressed
which means it builds pressure and then
every time you open up the water tap the
water comes out here and the balloon
just expands a little bit
but it means that the pump doesn't have
to go on and off every time you open up
the tap
now
in order to connect this you need a few
parts so the world of water components
is quite big you have a lot of different
options and within each option you also
have different sizes from one inch one
and a half inch etc
so it's quite some puzzling to make this
happen so the components i use is what i
could find here locally after a lot of
puzzling in the store
so let me explain what you need to hook
this up first you need this part and
this makes sure water can only flow in
one direction as you can see
that's where the water could flow
and not in that way it's because this
little valve make sure it can only open
in
one way so you can really build up
pressure in a closed system on one side
next we're gonna have a t-piece
so this piece has a few additional holes
which are very crucial to set up a
pressure tank
first i need to add a little connector
in between
now we connect it
[Music]
so now we can add a few additional items
first
a bar meter so this thing measures the
pressure in your system then we have a
pressure switch
so this thing is wired to your
electronics and connected to the pump
and it measures the amount of pressure
you have in your system and if it goes
too low it would tell the pump to start
and if it's at a good level it would
stop the pump so this is very important
to maintain your water pressure
so we're going to put that on top
then we're going to use another t piece
you can probably find other parts for
this but this is what i could find so
this is going to use to connect the tap
now we can put on the top
now this is not going to be the final
tap this is just going to be a tap for
maintenance to make sure we can empty
the system
and then we're going to add a main
switch
so just make sure we can turn off our
whole water system at once
next we're gonna get a tube to connect
actually to the pressure tank in our
case we use a flexible tube
we're gonna mount that to the back of
the t-piece
and what would actually also be good to
have is a pressure valve to make sure if
there's an overload of pressure the
valve releases it i couldn't find that
all these components are now sourced
here locally in the hardware stores
trying to puzzle it together
it takes quite some time actually
you can also buy a tps online as a kit i
could only find them in the us but it
seems very convenient because you kind
of use the same components but they
already pre-selected it put it together
so you don't have to go to the whole
hassle of assembling this
so from here we basically have the water
system and then we're going to use some
stainless steel tubes to connect it to
our shower washing machine sink
everything comes after here we're also
going to still seal some filters because
we're going to use the water from the
well to make sure we can filter it so
now i'm going to wire everything up and
then we're going to pipe everything up
and then make sure
it runs
so when putting all the pieces for the
pressure tank together i discovered a
new local shop and found this pressure
release valve the part i was missing and
the water meter now the meter isn't
really needed but seems like a fun thing
to keep track of our water usage
so after putting together all the
components it's time to make a box where
we are going to connect all these parts
as a base we will use two of these
holders we still have them laying around
from our old workspace for hanging big
bags with plastic
with a little modification we can use
them to mount the box on the container
[Music]
so
[Music]
so this is actually super nice because i
recently discovered that we can use our
welding machine on the generator i
thought it would be way too heavy
because we kind of have a powerful one
but turns out as long as you weld sort
of not too high amperage you can just
run it which has been super nice no more
stick welding and no more borrowing we
can just use our own welder i like it
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
now the box is ready we can hook it up
to the container and start assembling
the system
okay
[Music]
this is going to be the main water inlet
for the container everything inside is
already hooked up we just need to make
sure the water flows and everything is
connected together
so the water tubes don't leak and the
water is flowing
and we also need to connect the water
pump to our shoulder system we set up an
update 22 to make sure it gets
electricity to pump the water up
alright so now it's almost there to turn
it on just one last thing to do so next
we're going to prepare the ground to put
the tubes in because we need to get the
water from the well
to our base camp so we're going to dig a
few centimeters into the soil
where we can put the tubes we're going
to keep the lines as straight as
possible so it's easier
and then we go from this side where the
well is to
here
so first we're going to the workspace
and then going to the town center so we
need to make
a long line
here
so it's going to be a lot of digging
[Music]
all right so here we have it uh that
went a bit harder than expected
so i was super rocky
hurt my hand
so i think we're just gonna continue
throughout the days to take a little bit
every day
like free gym
[Music]
so all the slots are duck
now we're gonna put in
tubes
[Music]
all right so the well is now closed off
all the hoses and electricity cables are
in
so now let me show you our full line and
actually turn it on
so here we dig
it into the road
we actually close it off already so the
cars can pass
here it's still open
well we first wanted to test it before
we would actually close off everything
so still open the electricity spread
here
to the workspace
and continues to go so one pipe now is
for the water input and one is for
electricity
here is a sewage pipe coming out still
need to connect that
but first you want to actually have the
water
here it goes into the container
from here
then we have the system with the filters
water meter pressure tank everything is
here
filters are not installed yet because
first we just want to have it run for a
while
before we would actually
start filtering
the pressure tank there's a balloon
inside i now pumped it with a bike pump
it is possible but we don't have a meter
so actually not sure how much the bar is
on this one
the pressure
so probably you need to do that properly
later but i kind of just really want to
test it
and also added another fuse box that
goes to the pump
to make sure we can turn it on so i
guess maybe
it's time to just do that kinda scared
all right
i hear the pump i hear the water
i hear some air flowing it's not a good
sign
so rita can you share the water yes the
water look at this
water
[Music]
water
water
finally we have water and we don't need
to go to town every day to fill up jerry
cans
so we can finally use as much water as
we need the well fills up super quick
the neighbors say that they drink from
water from the well but for that we
still want to do some water tests
and we have a good feature that comes
with running water which is
a washing machine
cool
so what's the first thing you're going
to do with all this water
very exciting thing i think i will
wash deeply the kitchen
so the water is now connected to the
town center and the last part was
actually super easy to connect it
since it was that easy i thought it
would also be nice to maybe build an
outdoor shower an outdoor sink
[Music]
so
[Music]
so all the tubes are now connected and i
kind of want to give it a quick test run
to see if it doesn't leak and also
because uh she's [ __ ] hot but there
isn't anything connected there yet so it
would just come out i guess
hopefully
all right so that is running but yeah as
you can see we don't really have a
shower hat we need one but i was looking
into the store and you only find this
very shitty plastic
i don't know they feel they're gonna
break anytime soon i don't like that
i think that's the pump
turning on
anyway we still need to connect that one
on there but i think we're going to make
one myself with some leftover stainless
steel tube
[Music]
so i wanted to drill some holes but the
drill was too small for the hat so it
didn't fit in
and i tried to hammer it
[Music]
yeah really good to have running water
especially after almost a year of
filling up cherry cans
we can now take fresh shower wash our
clothes and clean our dishes
so that's been really good
if you like what we do make sure to
visit support.projectcom.com
thank you guys for watching and see you
in the next video